élouan 16 ans se baladait avec sa petite
amie quand il a été poignardé en pleine
journée dans le centreville de Bordeaux
cela s'est passé près de la place
stalingrade vendredi 3 octobre son
assaillant tout aussi jeune que lui vêtu
d'une tenue de sport et au trait
maghrébain selon la mère de la victime
voulait lui extorquer son téléphone
portable il lui a demandé de le
déverrouiller et de supprimer la
fonctionnalité qui permet de retrouver
un iPhone perdu et Louan avait senti le
danger en voyant qu'il tenait sa main
droite dans sa poche il lui a dit qu'il
ne savait pas faire l'individu a alors
sorti son couteau de la poche et la
poignardé en visant l'abdomen
heureusement le jeune homme a eu le bon
réflexe de paré le coup et seulement
plusieurs tendons et nerfs de ses doigts
ont été sectionnés éouin a trouvé la
force de fuir malgré sa blessure mais a
été poursuivi sur plusieurs mètres par
l'assaillant avant qu'il soit dérouté
par des passants dont un qui a fait un
Garau à l'adolescent en attendant les
secours éouan a ensuite été opéré en
urgence mais le jeune adolescent qui est
apprenti en CAP plomberie électricité ne
sait pas encore s'il pourra poursuivre
son année scolaire ses parents choqués
et en colère ont porté plainte samedi et
une enquête a été ouverte quand on vise
le ventre de quelqu'un avec un couteau
ce n'est plus une agression c'est une t
de meurtre vous vous rendez compte se
faire planter à 16 ans en pleine journée
juste pour une promenade à Bordeaux
quand le policier me dit lors de notre
dépôt de plainte que Bordeaux est une
jungle ce n'est pas normal prendre un
coup de couteau à Bordeaux c'est devenu
comme aller acheter une baguette de pain
le matin il faut donner plus de moyens
aux policiers et se battre contre
l'insécurité